hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem kurzen info video ich wollte mal
ein paar infos hier raus knüppeln ich
habe schon länger kein explizites info
video dings über so ein paar sachen
gemacht deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
okay das muss jetzt wirklich mal wieder
sein denn es sind ein paar sachen
aufgekommen die ihr mich gefragt habe
die mich beschäftigen und die ich
einfach mal sagen wollte also ihr seht
hier gerade meinen desktop dellen habe
ich gerade ein wenig aufgeräumt also ich
hab alles einfach auf dem zweiten
bildschirm gezogen
leider geht zum echten leben nicht so
leicht da muss man schon richtig
aufbauen aber das ist ein anderes thema
und zwar wollte ich heute mit euch über
wartet vier dinge reden erstens konnte
zweitens christmas kraft drittens wird
challenger und viertens top craft ich
würde sagen kann direkt mit dem konto
kann und zwar habe ich vor ungefähr
einer woche habe ich bei meiner
facebook-seite gefragt die nun übrigens
auch immer ganz oben in der beschreibung
steht dort habe ich gefragt hey wollt
ihr dass sie den kontakt auf contractor
mache oder also ich das vielleicht doch
lieber auf konz blog machen weil das ist
ja mehr sondern gelabere und auf
kontrast das ähnlich nur micro bla bla
bla bla und ich bin auf einen entschluss
gekommen den mir auch ein paar leute
geschrieben haben und jemanden
hinterlegt das doch einfach mit
irgendwelchen was du in minecraft machst
oder so aber da ich nicht so gut über
ein thema quatschen kann während ich sag
mal zeuge habe ich mir etwas besser
überlegt ich gucke in letzter zeit eine
menge kommentare von youtube live
cookies von youtube an die judoka hero
judoka hero 100 oder irgendwie sowas
halt so coole leute und da hab ich mir
gedacht komm kommentare bockig ganz ganz
damals meinen kommentare gemacht da
können sie vielleicht noch ein paar
daran erinnern in mw3 mein erster skoda
war gleich 24 zu zwei oder irgendwie
sowas soll wieder kommentiert und etwa
habe ich dann wieder gelöscht weil ich
damit überhaupt nicht zufrieden war
naja egal jedenfalls habe ich gedacht
dass ich so etwas auch mal machen könnte
allerdings anders und zwar auf eine art
die es
die so noch nie gesehen habe natürlich
werden jetzt sollte ankommen aber ich
habe einen tschechien gewinnt ihr habt
die abonnenten das auch schon gemacht
und da ein amerika das auch schon
gemacht
man kann nicht auf youtube machen was
noch nie jemand nicht gemacht hat aber
ich habe mir das noch nie gesehen und
zwar mache ich ein kommentare in
minecraft das heißt die spiele zb hunger
games oder ich spiele es gibt auch
paintball mittlerweile capture the flag
gibt es gibt auch cod mods mittlerweile
also irgendwie sowas in der richtung
mache ich hinterlege das einfach oder
irgend eine aufnahme aus dem live stream
livestream link ist auch in der
beschreibung
ja ich nehme halt ich denke es wird
meistens hunger games sein ich nehme das
auf den ton von minecraft neben einfach
ein paar runden auf und die hinterlege
ich dann und quatschen dann nachher dazu
also nicht live kommentiert sondern dann
schon nach kommentiert und da suche ich
mit einem matten raus wie zum beispiel
dinge wie die wahl von obama wie wird
man berühmt auf youtube so alles
mögliche was halt kommentierte auch in
den videos machen machen ich mach' ich
quasi in minecraft sag ich mal
also so habe ich mir das jetzt gedacht
ist wird die nächste woche irgendwann
der zweite oder ich sag mal einfach
schon der erste kontakt ist das erste
kommentare in minecraft kommen wenn ich
ein passendes gameplay finde und macht
mir doch bitte keinen stress ich habe
nicht so viel zeit mittlerweile weil ich
meistens jetzt nur noch circa gegen 8
uhr in der woche jeden tag zu hause bin
also das ist nicht ganz so toll
ich wollte nur sagen dass der konter
kalt hier auf dem kanal stattfinden wird
mit minecraft hunger games videos
unterlegt und dann werde ich das team
coachen die ihm in die kommentare
schreiben könnt also das könnt ihr jetzt
schon mal machen wenn ihr wollt das war
das erste thema kommt zum zweit- bis zur
zweiten sache hier xms kräfte wie ihr
seht schon alles vorbereitet bis zum 24
dezember so sehen die tanten jetzt aus
keine anzeigen
das ist nicht gut hier ist es nicht egal
das ist ein bisschen angepasst oder das
als mir sagen passiere so logo is kraft
bei schnee männer im hintergrund seine
skipiste genommen aus den alpen blabla
hat ihr wie ihr wenn ihr auf die zahlen
achtet klappt die zahlen nicht immer mit
der anderen art gemacht ich finde dass
vor allem am 24 sehr feierlich diese
zahl die habe ich selber gemalt
da habe ich nicht so eine schöne zahl
gefunden wird die genommen die auch sehr
schön also immer halt so ein paar sachen
eigentlich schon mir mitgegeben
und die habe ich halt alle wirklich
schon vorbereitet hier ist das am netz
und ich muss halt nur noch aufnehmen die
sache ist jetzt die ich hatte dass er
schon mal gemacht als ich hab das halt
gelöscht weil ich damals keine rechte an
muslimen hatte die dschungelwelt aber
die habe ich jetzt mittlerweile
eingeräumt
und letztes mag ich das so genommen
gemacht dass ich das so gemacht habe
dass ich das so gemacht habt lässt das
so gemacht habe dass es so gemacht habe
dass das so gemacht
ich habe das so gemacht dass ich ich hab
mit austria habe ich in minecraft jede
folge ein neues gebäude gebaut was ihr
uns in die kommentare schreiben könnte
die zum beispiel einen schneemann einen
schnee dorf einen weihnachtsengel ein
tannenbaum irgendwie sowas in der
richtung
und dieses mal wird das definitiv nicht
umsetzbar seien von ostsee habe ich noch
keine antwort bekommen und die sache ist
einfach die dass das zu lange dauern
würde das heißt wir würden dann
eventuell ich mit einem partner oder ich
alleine ich weiß noch ich würde ich
jeden tag eine folge hochladen wo ich
einfach in einer schneewelt irgendwas
bauen werde oder irgendwie sowas und das
recht an christmas kraft nennt schreibt
mir also wenn ihr da ideen habt bitte
ein wenn die kommentare schreiben
wer auf jeden fall wäre ich sehr
verbunden und das war's damit nächstes
thema für challenger wir hier seht sehen
wer sich ihr seht es nicht aber wir
haben als martin und ich haben wir
challengers schon zuende aufgenommen
schon als ich den ersten part
hochgeladen habe haben wir schon zuende
aufgenommen gehabt bei martin hat an dem
abend bei mir gepennt und habe mir
gedacht komm ein bisschen langeweile
schnapp dir einfach mal laptop dann
nehme ich warte dann habe ich auch schon
ganzen samt mails alles fertig gemacht
und die werde ich dann einfach nur also
ich hab die ganzen folgen auch schon
hochgeladen
nur halt nicht veröffentlicht also da
müsst jetzt gar nicht sagen hey du hast
ja so viele projekte auf einmal schaffte
das denn noch alles also der challenger
schon fertig und nach wird challenger
habe ich dann nur noch tropic kraft und
together show unterhalten lost und wenn
robbie kraft dann also nicht ob ich noch
verbessern und dann kommt irgendwann
doch im dezember christmas kraft und
dann ist halt im dezember irgendwann ist
in der gruppe i kraft und xs kraft zu
ende und dann habe ich halt nur noch die
geldtasche und lost und dann wird wieder
ein anderes frei kommen also ihr werdet
schon sehen wie das dann alles so
abläuft nur mit
man hat immer leute challenger blabla
ich hab mir tipps für dich wir haben
schon zu ende aufgenommen also bringt
das alles nichts die videodateien seht
ihr nicht weil ich habe die schnell
hochgefahren es muss halt noch hochladen
und ja das erst mal zur challenger dann
letztes thema trophy kraft topkräfte
viel passierte zwar also de plaisir die
habe ich auch schon erstellt für die
nächsten folgen und zwar als mir dort
ein fehler passiert ich habe nämlich
hier seht ihr die spur von minecraft als
ich nicht mehr bei minecraft also bild
und ton spur anders auf also nicht
zusammen
hier seht ihr mich wie ich jetzt gebe
ich einen kleinen spoiler noch dran sind
hier wo kann man das denn ungefähr sehen
wie mein haus nachher aussehen wird ich
habe mich auf jeden fall in sonnenberg
eingegraben und habe den richtig schön
ausgehöhlt da seht ihr das schon system
und das so sieht das dann alles aussieht
echt extrem geil aus und die sache dann
einfach ich wusste nicht dass man erst
die copy kraftfeld reinkommen wenn man
wirklich also die sache ist die ich hab
schon bis einschließlich folge 5
aufgenommen so wie es da seht oder folge
6 oder folge für folge 5 jedenfalls hat
mir dann jemand jetzt ich hab's halt
alles wirklich schon aufgenommen und mir
habt dann jemand bei part 2 kommentare
geschrieben du man muss sich schon einen
stuhl setzen und dann in der nacht
beziehungsweise beim sonnenuntergang
pina colada trinken dann ist das so wie
wenn man ins netter portal geht dass man
nicht in die newa welt kommt sondern
dass man in die tropische welt kommt ich
habe das getestet will mich im
sonnenstuhl bin auf einer komplett
anderen welt und komme nie mehr zurück
dabei ist das was wir dann bisher
gemacht haben ist eigentlich mehr oder
weniger unnötig ich weiß nicht ob man
ein wenig doch zurückkommen kann durch
irgendeinen wasser portal oder so habe
ich gehört aber jedenfalls ist das was
wir bisher gemacht haben unnötig ich
lade euch die folgen trotzdem hoch bis 5
nur dann solltet ihr wissen in part 6
gehen wir dann in diese andere welt wo
alles ganz ganz anders ist ein total
tropisch das ist auf jeden fall richtig
geil ich habe es wirklich schon alles
aufgenommen hier alles mögliche und kann
deswegen erst in part 6 dort hingehen
und ja also erst ein paar 6 gehen wir
dann in die tropische welt von da her da
bitte jetzt nicht mehr so viel stören
und ich weiß das schon so dann kommen
jetzt noch zu der letzten sache habe ich
ganz vergessen hier aufzuschreiben
tipps kann löschen ich habe ein zweiter
kanal dort fragen mich total viele du
hatte man zwei kanal wenn du paar videos
blabla idee ich rate nicht wartet ich
bin ich hier mal eben auf einem kanal
erwarte pause scheiß autoplay hätte
viele klicks der geldgeile zack macht
jetzt hier los
ihr seht ihr ein tolles internet heute
hat er doch noch werbung vor gott sorgt
pause deswegen kanal den sollte
eigentlich kennen so hier unten 2 kanal
und freunde also hier konz blog einfach
draufklicken einem zweit kanal so dann
seit ich hier auf meinem zweikanal die
sachen hoch wie wie loks also wo ich wo
ich einfach drauflos quatsche das ist
was anderes als der konnte wo ich
möchten thema zurechtlegen
hier sind einfach nur ein paar träsch
sachen sagt ich hatte minecraft sonic
adventure bagdad hat auch plan gegen die
10.000 aufrufen warum sowas wie
minecraft 1.9 installation tutorial wie
ich im real life mit martin auto
gefahren bin froh dass länder forest map
wo ich gesagt haben komm auf kontraste
schon so viel dazu bei die wir hier
solche videos leid ich dann alle hier
auf konz block hoch also da einfach mal
vorbeischauen kommt blog wartet mal hier
zum beispiel jetzt die götter schaue ich
mir ausgesucht episode 29 grad noch
offen
da seht ihr nun immer oben in der
beschreibung bit.ly / kfd ist mein
facebook ist meine facebook-seite zwar
fragen mich da immer noch leute hey du
wie machst du das hier mit seinen themen
runden blabla
ich nehme keine youtube ps an mit themen
oder hier dingsbums jeweils das facebook
nachricht sondern wenn ich auflege der
post sich bei der facebook seite hält
der bands auf oder blau und dann könnt
ihr mir dazu halt herr themen
unterschreiben das heißt einfach oben
stehen bit.ly dfb licon und immer auf
dem neuesten stand sein wenn ich bilder
news infos und videos hochladen also
dann einfach draufklicken licon basta so
und außerdem sich jetzt auch immer zwei
kanal konstrukt und mein livestream von
buy
y / conlife als ich hab das alles ein
bisschen anders strukturiert damit der
immer wissen was da gerade abgeht bei
mir und so dass hier oben sind halt
alles die habe ich den letzten mal
ausgeblendet da sind halt alles ein paar
links liegt da oben drin habt wie zum
beispiel auch top craft wo ja mal kurz
drauf klicken das hab ich nämlich
abgespeichert und zwar kann man bei
tropic kraft moment neben hier oft
objekt kann man hier auf recipes geht
das wenn ich den nächsten offen haben so
sieht die neue top craft welt außen die
wir dann auch folge 6 reini werten da
haben wir hier die ganzen recipes die
werde ich mir nebenbei offen haben also
damit ich das ein bisschen besser
vorbereitet bin und dann würde ich sagen
das sind zwei mosley ich demnächst
vorstellt werde ich quatsche wieder viel
zu viel
ich würde einfach sagen wenn euch das
video gefallen hat das ist die info
wieder scheiß egal ob das bewertet oder
nicht ich hoffe nur dass dort alles ein
bisschen verstanden also dass er wissen
müsste noch mal ganz ganz kurz
zusammengefasst kontakt kommt ab sofort
ab als kommentare als minecraft hunger
games kommentare hier auf dem kanal
zweitens christmas kraft startet bitte
ideen in die kommentare der challenge
habe ich komplett aufgenommen da brauche
ich keine tipps mehr traffic kraft
abfolge 6 gehen wir die tropische welt
und ich habe auch ein zweiter kanal also
da einfach mal vorbeischauen dann würde
ich sagen sehen uns beim nächsten mal
euch noch ein wunderschönes wochenende
ich habe euch alle liebten dicken
knutscher wangen bis zum nächsten mal